on to the day's other top story the
remaining suspect did a mass stabbing in
canada has died as a result of
self-inflicted injuries miles anderson
had been on the run but was arrested
near rosthern in saskatchewan
10 people were killed and at least 18
injured on sunday victoria gatenbee
reports
a manhunt lasting three days and
stretching over three vast prairie
provinces ended on the side of a road in
saskatchewan miles sanderson was
arrested on suspicion of mass murder but
later died from self-inflicted injuries
he was the only occupant of the vehicle
when he was arrested shortly after being
arrested he went into medical distress
emergency medical services responded and
he was transported to hospital in
saskatoon and that's where he was
deceased
sanderson's brother who was also a
suspect was found dead on monday near
the scene of the crimes
ten people were stabbed to death in the
james smith crew reserve in saskatchewan
on sunday it's one of the worst mass
murders in canadian history mark
arkhan's sister was killed as she
shielded her children
right right outside of her home
she was killed
by senseless axe
her son she was protecting her son
she was protecting these three little
boys
this is why she's a hero in addition to
the 10 people stabbed to death 18 people
were injured canadian prime minister
justin trudeau has promised additional
resources for the traumatized community
local leaders say people are struggling
to come to terms with the attack we are
probably one of the most resilient races
on the planet
but we have our breaking points you know
my feelings
um as an indigenous person
is that
it's just more trauma
layered on top of what the community
already lives with
intergenerational trauma
mental health
sanderson was wanted for breaching
parole in may he'd served part of a
sentence for assault and robbery police
in saskatchewan are facing questions
about why it took four months to find
him they say the motive for the brutal
attacks remains unknown victoria
gatenbee al jazeera well let's bring in
christopher old corny's reporter at
western standard an online news and
opinion platform focusing on western
canada been following the story and
joins us from regina good to have you
with us again on the program christopher
i mean the police in the last few hours
have given a very detailed methodical
account of what happened and when just
to allay any suspicion around the
circumstances
to this latest part of the story
what do you make of what's been said and
the issues around the arrest
well they did have a press conference
that started about an hour ago where the
head of the rcmp uh did clearly lay out
what had happened uh throughout today
from the report of uh the pickup truck
being stolen
uh about 210 local time uh at 3 30 they
forced that pickup truck off the road
um and were able to arrest miles
anderson at that time
now there is uh one photo which we have
up on our site of miles standing uh
with handcuffs on and several police
officers around him at that moment in
time he does not look to be in any sort
of medical distress
um one eyewitness uh on the scene i was
driving by in a pickup truck actually
said miles was
smiling and laughing and seemed to like
the attention that he was getting
which an individual like him uh that
would go and do this um who knows what's
actually going on inside his head uh
shortly after that uh was when he went
into what they called medical distress
and went by ambulance to saskatoon which
is the nearest big city to the royal
university hospital uh escorted by
police cars obviously and he passed away
at some point we're not sure it was in
the ambulance or when he arrived at the
hospital but they did find a knife in
the vehicle and of course uh the police
saying that there will be an independent
inquiry now into how he uh died and the
circumstances around that we will have
to wait and see
at the moment you know you've been
following the story for the past few
days and we got a small glimpse in
victoria's report about
the the reaction uh that the community
is is dealing with i mean what's your
sense of how devastated this particular
community have been uh in the light of
what's happened these past four five
days
um tremendous um most are actually not
on the james smith green nation right
now uh they're in hotels in
saskatoon uh basically because
most of the the james smith creation is
a crime scene um the clip you paid you
played just earlier there from the uh
was about the burns family
they can't go to their house because the
inside of their house is even a crime
scene
so
there was a ton of violence that
happened there's 13 different crime
scenes 12 of which are actually on the
james smith cree nation and one is in a
neighboring village called weldon
saskatchewan
the police have a ton of work ahead of
them to to sort through everything that
happened uh not only that uh the
the four-day manhunt that took them
you know all over saskatchewan uh trying
to find this individual as well and
christopher just briefly i mean this
community has really
lurched from one disaster to another
it's a deprived community generally uh
thought of it it's dealing with a
shooting only what a year ago that left
two dead in 2016 they had an oil
pipeline spill that contaminated their
main water supply they're also part of
uh the whole historic abuse case
revealed and blamed on the catholic
church's residential schools they have a
huge drug problem huge unemployment this
community just can't seem to get a break
and the prime minister and the
government really have to focus on not
just this community but communities like
them across canada
yes and actually uh one of the head of
the chiefs of the federation of
sovereign uh indigenous nations actually
said he hopes that this
actually um
shines a spotlight on the drug and
alcohol problems that they do have so
that they can get uh more supports for
that and he actually said if anything
good comes out of it uh that could be
something that actually comes uh good
out of this like horrific tragedy
tragedy we've never had a
a mass killing and um rampage like this
before in canada and and this was done
with a knife not a gun as well indeed uh
tragic circumstances more questions
indeed more questions more investigation
we'll come back to you i'm sure as the
day and as the the weeks progress for
more uh insight for the moment
christopher altkon thanks for joining us
from regina
thank you